Roger stone won't now be leaving his
home in Florida for prison it is to sum
his reward for decades of loyalty to
Donald Trump Thank You mr. president
thank you for giving me the Opera
I don't think I at my age and in my
medical condition I would have survived
in a Cove infested prison it had been
clear hours before the bombshell dropped
that the president was weighing up
whether to save his old friend from
prison well I'll be looking at it I
think Roger stone was very unfairly
treated as were many people and in the
meantime Comey and all these guys are
walking around including Biden and Obama
because we caught them spying on my
campaign who would have believed that
one thank you
but his decision has caused outrage just
days before they were due to lock him up
it is another colorful chapter in the
life of a man who calls himself a
political dirty trickster he'd been
convicted of several offenses including
lying to Congress one of half a dozen
Trump aids convicted in the web weaved
by Special Counsel Robert Muller over
alleged collusion with Russia the
president's decision has angered
Democrats there are two systems of
Justice now in America one for criminal
friends of the president like Michael
Flynn and now Roger stone I am one for
everybody else and how about this from a
former Republican presidential candidate
Mitt Romney tweeted that it was
unprecedented historic corruption an
American president commutes the sentence
of a person convicted of lying to shield
that very president not surprisingly the
White House sees it differently in a
statement they said Roger stone is a
victim of the Russia hoax that the left
and its allies in the media perpetuated
for years in an attempt to undermine the
Trump presidency
Roger stone has already suffered greatly
he was treated very unfairly as were
many others in this case Roger stone is
now a free man there were no words from
the president
but there is anger in Trump's own
Justice Department over what some see as
a favor for an old political ally when
it comes to what he calls the collusion
delusion his president is more than
happy to settle some scores reg Milam
Sky News Los Angeles